you can see that this is just another
way of stating the words they've given
you to explain where they've been going
okay so this person my cup has started
at X in our bottom left-hand corner
they bought this fixed coexistence on
that barrier and then this five quarter
distance on this variant here at Davis
where they end up
okay now we're reading the question
carefully how far is y C of X now for
every single one of these notions and
this is quite common and you're going to
add construction on the unit to form the
angles or the lengths that they were
Church is fine so they said how far east
is Y of X so recession is because into
the right okay that's all I need to do
is I need to take the case I go to the
right and you've just missed you okay
eventually at some point just go into
the night I will pass what right so this
is going to be a running or why the
right angle
what are those North what is vertical
and horizontal lines represent their
north and east right they're always
going to be perpendicular to each other
so that's a really important thing
having that right angle in there okay
how far east is so what's the value on
trying to find what this is yeah this
long one that I've just told you
okay so I have another give a label to
so I can work out what would you like to
call it E is sure let's call this each
one okay I might even capital because
I'm going to might have another
concentration elsewhere so fine all
right now what am I going to do to find
displayed what knowledge is important
concerning going to periodically I can't
sir this ball to train table I need an
angle inside the Train also from this
study degree and Nestle interior just
like the excess coming into that angle
net by the way this is a special end
when you add these two together you get
ninety fourth quarter of the segment
this is a sink of the services father 20
we're going to do that okay with us
being recording left ripping particular
garden g-dragon on experience here the
two sides that are related to which
ratios on cosine is adjacent one point P
so we can write what is this pot a pot
one or something right yeah yeah ribbon
no Bob sure okay I can take cause 20
degrees is equal to adjacent on up on
you okay
I'm trying to find what E is by itself
so or like a do and already multiplied
by C so that is reading and then this
should give the numbers right third and
somewhat you provide five point six
yeah okay one all we have do with that
drowning look good yeah now um
George's not too far I just want to give
you a bit of a warning because some of
you there we go
some of you need to be really careful
with your calculators particularly if
you have a sibling who uses this and or
if you should lend it to someone like
that some of you may have your
calculator to exist okay you push it in
620 just like the rest of us period but
it's dedicated five point six you get
this number
okay now I'll come back to how that
number came up in a minute does that
look like a reasonable on now I think on
the face of it without thinking hard it
doesn't look like a reasonable answer
it's doable with what something
ridiculous like millions of kilometers
or 0.0001 kilometers so it seems like
it's in the right ballpark it was
completely wrong okay now how can it
work out that it is so wrong well to
tell with it 720 degrees right a pretty
small angle yet if you can imagine if
you can imagine these being quite close
together right I mean these sides are
close together because the angle between
them is small there we go if they click
together that the link has been pretty
close together as well which indeed they
are okay five points is correct so then
the question is well where where does
this number come from and why is it
wrong on your calculator and why don't
you do is press shift on the top left
then on the top right you know how does
that mode and stuff for when you do
stats and what have you okay if you
press shift and then mode you get a
whole bunch of options it's going to
present okay now a lot of options you've
never seen before you will never have to
use but in particular on the second row
on the second run I think it says this
to say that again yes that's right now
on what B stands for law they extend
forward with her degree and grab stable
radical dude no okay for you ever maybe
do that again Oh what is this what is
radio now radiant are another way to
measure angles just like I can measure
distances in kilometers
I can also measure distances in miles or
inches or whatever so this is a
different unit so if you are in the
wrong bow you're not going to cause 20
degrees by the way this is a reason why
I always like the degree symbol maybe
you don't you like to put 20 that's
enough and they're really good time to
write degree so the reason I do is
because there's a whole other way to
fight angles and six cause 20 Radian is
something completely different because
you did so when you're doing your sense
chest
you have to be quite careful then you go
just look at it they are in pretty close
okay take a little more attention okay
now the reason why you've never looked
at this is because in our course you
never have to worry about this it
appears in tuner and receiving extension
so on this is why I said if you lend it
or your siblings field hurts they may
have on and may have put it into this
mode even by accident okay the way you
will note is that at the top of your
display there what you want is for that
little tiny square that has the color
datatype allotted spirit that's what you
want if it's in the wrong mode you'll
see an R instead but it's so small you
cannot notice it but you'll just keep on
doing all your thoughts and your
so please make sure your calculator is
in the right mode and you'll get the
right answer